[Music]
Game of Thrones has returned with its
eighth season and the series promises an
epic showdown between the citizens of
Westeros and the knight Kings forces
though he's the big bad of the show is
actually very little that we know about
the night king and due to this there are
an abundance of theories floating around
the internet about his true identity and
power to clear things up I thought I'd
put together a breakdown of everything
that you need to know about the
character as well as some of the major
theories surrounding him there will be
some spoilers here so if you aren't
fully up to speed with the show yet then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I hope you enjoyed the
video
I'm your host definition and welcome to
the channel where we explain it so you
don't have to before becoming the evil
leader of the White Walkers the night
King was actually a first man that was
captured by a pack of the children of
the forest leaf who was amongst them
used dragonglass to press it against his
chest which turned him into the first
white Walker the ritual was originally
carried out by the children of the
forest because they wish to defend
themselves against Westeros were
slaughtering them in order to take their
resources of trees whilst the white
Walker army initially helped to defend
the children of the forest they
eventually turned on their masters and
this began what was known as the long
night in this the children ended up
having to team up with the first men and
together they drove the walkers up north
in the lands of always winter they faded
into folklore and obscurity until they
began to reappear in the events of the
show the reappearance of the night King
comes in season 4 when bran sees him in
a vision whilst initially the character
does not quite comprehend what's going
on he later realizes that this was a
vision of the night king picking up
crustless son through this vision bran
learns that the night king can transform
the living into white walkers upon touch
and this of course makes him infinitely
more dangerous the night King later
appears in season 5 during the
evacuation of hardhome leading the
attack he watches as his forces Sleater
town in what is one of the show's best
action set-pieces the night king
demonstrates his power which is the
ability to raid
the dead and recruit them to his army he
can also share weapons upon touch the
sense wargs which is how he's able to
detect bran ride dragons despite
apparently having no related bloodline
which I'll get into later and lived for
thousands upon thousands of years along
with this the knight King also possesses
the ability to mark people so that he
knows where they are at all times he
does this to bran which is how he's able
to track them to the cave and overrun it
which causes one of the best deaths in
the show
rest in peace horde or you will be
missed anyway the night king is - Creed
as the biggest threat to life and during
the white hunt Jon Snow and a band of
warriors attempt to capture away in
order to present it to the High Lords of
Westeros as proof of the impeding threat
this puts them in a lot of danger though
and eventually they get surrounded by
the creatures and Daenerys is forced to
rescue them whilst they get away the
night King manages to bring down one of
their dragons and reanimate it which
allows him to attack the wall and bring
it down the storming Westeros with his
forces in season eight the night King
and his forces attack last hearth
Massacre the forces and pin Ned embed to
the wall as a calling card and that's
everything we know so far about the
character so what exactly are his goals
well this depends purely on how much
weight you put into the theory that bran
is in fact the antagonist if this is the
case and the night King is bran and his
gold could purely be to die and or stop
himself travelling back in time before
he's able to be captured by the leaf
children this is prophesized to happen
when Brandon develops the green singing
ability that will allow him to journey
back so the night Kings goals could
purely be to stop this from happening by
killing bran before the event doing this
would allow him to finally rest as his
immortality is given credence by the
fact that the children of the forest
killed him when he was out of his own
time so therefore he is not subject to
its rulings whilst many argue that bran
is the three-eyed Raven and therefore
not the night king there could actually
be two versions of the character that
splits you to a paradox and both need to
stop the other so that they are either
not created
killed the other theory of the night
Kings identity pulls from his calling
card which looks eerily similar to the
Targaryen house crest the symbol has
appeared throughout the show at many
important moments and it could be that
the night king is none other than Haris
the second Targaryen the Mad King
brought back from the dead this will
explain his keen ability to ride dragons
and also why he wishes to seek revenge
on Westeros so much he was initially
ousted and destroyed by the people of
the land and therefore this makes sense
as to why he's on his quest whilst the
timelines may not match up he could be
the night King leading the forces and
there could be another secret leader of
the whites that it's using him as a
distraction so all the forces for their
effort into fighting him whether this
happens or not is a different thing
altogether but it's probably the theory
that I side with the most we of course
we'll all find out in the next handful
of episodes but in the meantime I'd love
to hear your thoughts on why you think
it shows going and what else you think
could happen down the line I'll be doing
an update video on this topic once the
season 8 finale is ahead so make sure
you keep an eye out for that and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the season a premiere which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
Definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]